now we're fortunate enough to be in
position where you know we are
incredibly selective we won't you know
we could have five movies come that say
will you come on to this and produce it
there go movies they're happening I I
don't think we would jump onto those
unless we absolutely loved it and feel
like we provide value to the project you
know I think we tend to want to be more
actively involved in a project and
passively so I think you know hence why
we like to develop our own material why
we like to kind of control it and
control how the movie comes together and
then sometimes the movie kind of goes
out of your hands a bit but comes
together miraculously like the post
which was you know for someone who
idolized as an understatement
as a kids even Spielberg I you know had
a poster of him on my wall it was the
dream of a lifetime getting to sit
beside him as he directed and watch him
and learn from him so you know there are
always fun moments involved I know the
post is a film that is very timely right
now yeah won't go into some of the
reasons why but you talk about making it
and just the process of seeing it sure
well when we started developing that
script with Liz Hannah we didn't know
that the film was gonna be as relevant
as it became you know this was pre the
election it was actually at a time when
we thought we were gonna have our first
female president and we thought this is
a movie that's about female empowerment
and about a woman finding her voice and
we thought it was relevant in that way
little did we know that it was about to
be relevant in a whole nother way and I
think what was amazing about that and
and you know we still have to pinch
ourselves that had happened in the way
that it did is most movies don't you
know get greenlit have a start date two
months later with a release date six
months after that in time for Oscar
season you know so it was very much when
it when the green light came
it was a kind of a stunning moment
seeing it may be that the in a big
theater just with the guest crew the
first time I saw was actually in a small
theatre I saw it at Amblin at Steven's
office in his private screening room and
it was I mean it's just one of the most
incredible experiences I think of my
life especially in my career just
watching this thing that you know we
spent every day watching how Steven
worked and where his mind was going with
decisions and then seen it so
effortlessly and beautifully come
together and and then to see our company
name up there and their credit it was
just like this is a dream is a childhood
dream never thought it would happen so
it was emotional how did you attach
Steven spielberger how did you approach
him well I should say we didn't you know
the script had kind of taken on a life
of its own and had become quite a
popular script in town and at that point
there were many buyers involved that
wanted it and wanted to take it off the
table and it ultimately went to Amy
Pascal who you know was in her new post
as a producer after having run Sony for
a long time and Amy was incredibly
gracious and collaborative and couldn't
have been a better partner on the
project and with Amy we then set it up
at Fox and then together it was one of
these questions I remember the first
time we talked about directors and
Stephen siller's name came up and it was
he's doing another movie and he's a
that's the long shot of all long shots
so we kind of just didn't think about it
and then Amy received an incoming call
that said Stephens movie is gonna push
and Tom and Meryl we want to send it to
all three of them at the same time and
it was on a Friday afternoon that we got
that call and by Monday all three had
read it and wanted to do it what was
that weekend like
actually not bad because we thought it
was so far-fetched with we didn't think
it was in the realm of possibility I
mean we get calls all the time on
projects of Oh so-and-so
let's send it to them and you know and
nine out of ten times it doesn't pan out
so I think we never thought that the
Monday call was going to come the way it
did so the I didn't think about it much
of that weekend but then when we heard
it it was like a you know took your
breath away thank you for watching our
interview with Trevor white recently
we've begun hosting live events where we
bring together the film courage
community if you enjoy watching this
channel we encourage you to join us this
upcoming Tuesday October 23rd we have a
class with Pamela J Smith entitled
mythic challenges how writers can create
stories that change the world we think
is going to be fantastic check out the
link below and hopefully we'll see you
there